jacques c'est la première fois que vous
entrez dans un confessionnal
oui quel effet ça vous fait je vous
dirais que j'aime beaucoup l'atmosphère
des églises l'atmosphère du sacré et
donc ça me fait le même effet vous êtes
déjà allongé sur le divan d'un psy quête
d'un petit quart d'heure même pour
rigoler pour rigoler b avec des gens qui
n'étaient pas aussi ma mère n'avait pas
besoin de porter l'étoile jaune
elle était jaune de la tête aux pieds
c'est cette sensibilité de colonisés qui
a guidé votre vie je crois oui c'est
pour ça que j'avais défendu barbie non
pas comme un tortionnaire nazi mais
comme membres d'une armée d'occupation
comme l'armée française en algérie où
l'armée américaine au vietnam où l'armée
russe en afghanistan pour moi à barbie
est un personnage tragique de notre
temps c'est le fichier subalternes d'une
armée d'occupation
dans un pays qui résiste vous avez dit
comme roger nimier tout humanisme et
étrangers expliquez vous je veux dire
ceci c'est que il y à une certaine
morale qui se cache derrière les mots
humaniste derrière les mots droits de
l'homme qui exprime le
l'état de la société en europe à l'heure
actuelle cette morale cette vision du
monde qui n'aimait pas général
d'ailleurs est le résultat du lycée est
l'aboutissement d'une histoire et je
trouve que vouloir imposer cette vision
du monde à tous les pays à toutes les
nations c'est faire fi de leurs cultures
différentes de leur histoire différente
leur vision du monde qui est différente
c'est manifestement n'avoir pas du
cinglé est ce que vous auriez défendu
adolf hitler
s'il était venu me voir et qu'il m'avait
dit je suis certainement l'homme dans
l'histoire du monde qui est l'objet des
accusations les plus graves
je crois que c'est incontestable mon
procès effet d'avancer est encore une
cause perdue mais parmi les millions
d'avocats qui a dans le monde je pense
que vous êtes le seul capable de donner
à mes actes leur vraie signification
leur vraie dimension jeu ou non pas
m'excuser je vous demande de décrire
fins de donner à ma vie sa dîme sa
véritable dimension à ce moment là je
crois que j'aurais accepté pendant les
six ans vous avez disparu vous étiez où
quelque part vous dirai jamais vous
savez les liaisons qu'elle soit
amoureuse aux politiques qu'on cache
sont toujours et plus ça vous fait mal
d'être un écrivain raté d'abord écrivain
raté il aurait fallu que je sois le jeu
la volonté d'être écrivain je suis un
livre c'est l agenda c'est assez longue
ça dépend et comme on le prend mais le
ce que je veux dire c'est le travail
d'avocat dans comme je conçois est un
travail de création aussi avec son
originalité c'est quoi la beauté du
crime
la beauté du crime c'est cela ne veut
pas dire que tous les crimes sont beaux
la beauté du greaves et que certains
craignent prennent une signification
universelle
est-ce que vous avez le sens du péché
non et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus